my name is your agoura i'm the CEO of
Wolfram mathcore and we developed system
modular so this was we talked where I
will displaying what has to happen
during the last year and basically
anything that has happened since the
last conference so what I will will go
through is some of you might not be
familiar with system over since before
so we'll start with very quick
introduction of what system model a's
then i will show so what was new some of
what was new in system or 4.1 which came
something around februari then we have a
couple of new model libraries related to
the system of earlier we'll talk about
and then we have an upcoming release in
a few weeks of system or 4.2 so we'll
include that too and and finally I'll
but we wrap wrapping up by giving a some
kind of a presentation of upcoming the
upcoming presentations that we will have
in the in their upcoming days okay so
let's start with what sister mother is
those of you that have been to my talks
before I have seen this several times
before those that Hammond perhaps
haven't seen it before a basically
system owner is an environment
environment to build models of dynamic
systems and typical complex dynamic
systems those systems could be something
in aerospace like in helicopter which
will see examples of later on or it
could be the human body or it could be
something let's say a satellite or
anything where you want to study how
things are happening over time and want
to understand more of it so I will start
by doing a very small example to give
you an idea what you do and now it is a
toy example but we will investigate we
will try to model a squirrel and that is
shooting with a machine gun to try to
rocket himself up about this statue of
liberty so what we have
and I will start by opening in the
modeling system modular so what we'll
have is basically a model for the
squirrel getting there okay we have a
model for the squirrel up in the
left-hand corner we have a model of the
machine gun a position sensor that the
senses where how high the squirrel is at
every point in time and what you've done
in sister modular is you have a
drag-and-drop environment to come
connect these kind of components and you
create can create your own components
like in this case we have created a
squirrel component if you go into the
machine gun we can see that that is
built up by other components some of
them like the shot counter here is a
standard component available in the
library while others are in this case we
have a magazine of a bullet which is
something that we have developed here
and if I double click into that i will
have other components that that is built
up by so basically it's a
component-based environment to build up
any system that you want to study over
time so let's simulate this and so based
on those kind of drag and drop we create
a simulation executable and we can study
things like clicking here position
sensor and see the current height of our
squirrel so we can see here when he has
one bullet in the gun and issued he will
lift himself to about this is in meters
so hard for you to see but it's about
eight centimeters not very high but kind
of like this so then the question is
what happens if you have more guns or
more bullets and that's the purpose kind
of building a model you can investigate
different scenarios
so let's look at that from within
Mathematica and perhaps i'll shoot zoom
in a little bit here okay assuming in
quite a lot so basically we have a bunch
of parameters here for different things
like the bullet mass and why is that
keeping keep coming up a gun mass and so
on we set up parameters for what we want
to study and then we actual in this case
we put a human on it and we simulate and
in this case we will simulate several
different scenarios where we have
different number of guns 115 32 and so
on and once we simulated that we can
look at the position of this human when
is when he's shooting his gun so we can
see with one gun he will propel himself
like 0 point 3 millimeters nothing but
with 80 guns it will go up 12 meters
something like that it's pretty high but
more interestingly interestingly we can
see here that some of them the behavior
changes over time for instance I think
this one is interesting we can see that
we will start propelling yourself and
then after a while you will go downwards
question is why so that's the kind of
things you want to find out by by doing
simulations you you find okay why is
this happening now you have something to
understand and I want to explain that
today but you can find a blog that
actually explains that and shows what's
needed to fly over the Statue of Liberty
and actually to fly up 150 5 meters as a
human being shooting with some machine
guns a key AK forty-sevens if you want
to try it yourself so that was this the
motor is all about typically there are
ours decisions or cars or or human
bodies and things like that but
basically you want to study the dynamics
of it so what's new with 41 41 came
around februari I think perhaps March
had three main components into fmi
reliability and model development the
latter was
doing it easier to develop models as
several small things that are not
perhaps that spectacular to show but
that for the user adds a lot of value
because it makes a better working
environment if am I on the other hand is
a very important thing because what that
makes it makes it possible to exchange
your models with other tools and other
softwares so for instance you would
consider this example and I won't be
running it here live where we have a
controller developed by some third-party
and in this case they have actually
developed it don't tell it to anyone
seem in simulink but they have the
controller in simulink and then they
want to use a system where it can
actually model the physical behavior of
their vehicle better than they could do
in simulink so what they can do then is
export for simulink this fmi and then
they can import fmi into system over and
use that in the rest of the model yes
that's any other component in system
over that makes it possible then to test
the controller together with the model
of the plan to the car in this case and
study that so if mi allows you to
combine with about 30 40 different tools
importing and exporting your models and
running that so you have an integrated
tool chain where you can use it together
with whatever you are using at the
moment at your company or university the
other big thing there was reliability
and reliability and has been around in
Mathematica for quite a bit what we look
at here is this system will have a say
zoom out a bit three go we have a system
of a cessna conquest 441 with different
parts like flaps electrical system and
so on and what we want to look at our
different scenario failure scenarios but
before we do that let's open the model
in system model
so here it is and what we can see is
that it's hard for you guys to see but
here is a reliability we have a
reliability tab where you can set
reliability expressions for your model
and in this case we have the expression
very simple expression where shows them
in with in all the reliability
distributions that you have all the
distributions you have in Mathematica we
have chosen reliability distribution and
we said okay this reliability
distribution depends on hydraulic power
and flaps what happens to be this and
this component so both these have to
work in order for the whole system to
work of course the other system also
have to work but we have simplified this
DC for the sake of example I can then go
in for instance to the flaps and click
on the flaps and I will see that the
flaps have a dependency on reliability
distribution with all the pipes pipe
basic pipe one basic pipe 2 and so on
and that's all of these but also the
valves and so on and so forth have to
work and you build up the expression for
what's needed in order for this system
to work so that is included but of
course it still works to simulate as
usual so if i run a simulation of the
model and i will first kind of compile
the code this is what what's happening
here and once i can have compiled it i
can i can plot the results the dynamic
behavior of the system for instance i
create a new plot i could plot the flap
angle like that or in i can plot the
commanded flap angle so we can see a
behavior here we have a commando flap
angle in some kind of yellowish color
and the actual flap angle was to connect
me to their Wi-Fi here can i stop this
from appearing in some way i'm new to
mac so i don't know how to use my own
computer sorry how do i do that
I'll do that so I'm completely new and I
kind of not that good at using it yet
and so you can see the delays it takes
before it actually gets to the right
position there's actually some
difference here in between them so it
doesn't get exactly to the desired
position for some reason that might be
something to investigate but anyways so
we can see that but we can also in this
model there are included failures in
order of failure modes so we can
simulate that instead of simulating
again I will just show one of those
failure modes where we can see that what
we have tried to do here is to set the
flat bangles change that over time
according to this red curve but what we
see is the only thing that happens is it
pulls up to 10 degrees the flap and then
it stays there and the reason is that
there's a short circuit modeled in the
system right now so the question now we
can see okay which kind of consequences
does this have for our system but what
we want to know is also how likely is
this to happen so then you can have for
instance every pipe here that I showed
how to reliability distribution you can
see that they're modeled they can leak
they can have a restriction or they can
be completely blocked and we can then
look at what what's the reliability the
distribution for these systems and we
can see that the the whole system the
full system in green here is of course
more likely to fail than the sub
components of it and we can see how long
time they accept expected time to
failure is but we can also look at
things like this here where we look at
what which parts are the most important
for us to actually try to influence so
hard the most structural importance for
us so we can see that the blocks which
is as a structural importance much
higher than then leaks which and
restricted switch so probably it's more
important for us to look at how we
can limit that type of problem or we can
look at the entire system comparing the
flap system and hydraulic power system
and we can see that actually hydraulic
power system as model right now it's
more likely to to have an influence on
on the or ease of improvement so this
combined with the simulations and
actually understanding how severe
problem is is really important to be
able to improve your system so that was
real liability and there are other
things in for one but there is not that
much time so I will skip that two new
libraries model plug or do we knows how
many here have used Arduino sore know
what weenus so like her for you know
Audrina so hard windows are these simple
boards that you can buy at a very low
cost and run stuff on it so here we have
a library where you can connect easily
to those to create different labs there
is a lab right underneath here where you
can go and try that and tomorrow before
noon there will be a specific session
where you can go and try that so I will
not really show anything of that today
instead of we'll talk a little bit more
OPC classic OPC is basically using
process industry for data data
communication data gathering and it's
similar to to model plug but instead of
connecting to Arduino we're connecting
to process industries so we contact
connecting to a whole industry in order
to for instance control it and I
couldn't bring a process industry with
me so if my network is working here
let's see here that's the wrong network
let's connect to voice it airwolf is
that the one we want what password do we
have I was going
I might actually have that tab open
since before so that's okay let's keep
that I have it open since before so
basically what OPC does is and this is
from our blog it makes it possible to
connect system modular model with the
rest of your plant where different
operating systems to the actual control
Network and and the sensors and so on
and then you can use that as in this
example to control a bioethanol
production process so this is from a lab
and then then in this case it was done
for a lab but also done for a real
bioethanol process and you can use
system other than to create models of
the actual bioethanol production and use
that for instance for model predictive
control so it will look something like
this where you have your model here and
then you connect to different OPC
servers and clients to communicate with
the process and then you use that
predictions by your model to understand
how you should best govern your bio
ethanol production in order to optimize
production so that's a very important
library if you are within process
industry okay then four to it's very
quick here short things about a lot of
things performance usability integration
all of them are really good things
they're not always that easy to display
because it's like a lot of small things
for instance one of the things that we
improved a lot is the performance 442
the performance w Simplot which has been
rather slow sometimes so this is for a
bunch of X test examples we have and it
compares the total time for evaluating w
Simplot for each example here where one
is the same amount of time as it did in
41 so anything below one is
faster than previously which means that
every single example we have in this
test suite is it's faster n it should
always actually be faster and as long as
and the more dynamic system you have the
faster would be comparing to previous
results but even more so it will be more
correct more precise but it's pretty
dull to look at these kind of graphs
even if it's of course useful to know
which is faster so instead of looking at
graphs when looking at what has me
become better with on the compiler side
i will look at the scenario that has
been made much easier to do now with the
added performance so we have here this
has been done for a swedish company that
there were drones they want to land
oughta know Melissa with a drone on a
ship out in DC when it's high waves I
can't tell you hi how highways they are
should be able to cope with but they
have the system over what we did there
we developed the system on a model for
them in order to test landing on all
sorts of different sea conditions and
what you need to do is to run thousands
and thousands of simulations to test
landing after landing in order to secure
that independent of kind of the sea
condition you are at this will work so
let's look at one of those scenarios
there you go
so here what we will see is is the
vessel and this is not about having
fancy graphics so so we have not cared
anything about making fancy graphics but
we can see basically how the water is
moving relative to the vessel and we are
locked into the vessels or the chip so
we can that is not moving but that's
just because we chose the lock into it
without camera and we can see the drone
up there so what we're doing is running
simulation of the simulation of
different conditions here to see what
happens now when this tries to soon
tries to start let's just skip ahead a
little bit some running a little bit
late then then you can see here that it
tries to go down the land perhaps it has
already done its first attempt it goes
up again because it failed for some
reason and then it will give a new
attempt and it will be in able to end
when we did this what happened was that
we realized that their current control
system and landing strategy would result
in a lot of crashes if they would
implement that in the real life so by
being able to run these all different
scenarios of seas they could improve the
system and hopefully have something that
is much more reliable at the end of day
and that is one of the things that is so
much easier to do the amount of
simulations needed to do that its
enormous so getting improved for
performance is crucial for that so final
example two examples integration with
math mad math America is important of
course so for instance you can now
create data models from Mathematica so
for instance if I want to create some
noise input I'll try okay create the
model called noisy data with this
function and then i can connect that
into model like this and now hopefully
this yes before here the i'm running a
beta version and yes before i came here
this did not run very well so hopefully
does this time seems to be slow for some
reason her again so I cheated I was kind
of expecting that
and so I pre evaluate this and this will
happen after a while let's how do i
interrupting not like that I can
interrupt here I guess evaluation where
do I interrupt on the mac there I hope
know that work none of them so let's do
this let's create quickly quit it sorry
for that there you go quit and we'll go
to next so basically you have that and
there's we have to look like that that
is running slow instead I'll do the
final example here on small usability
things that have been added so let me
boo oh sorry and it is like that yep
backtick I guess there no there there
you go
so what I'm done here instead i create
the data model from mathematic i have a
list let's say i've generated that in
some way in Mathematica I'm not showing
the detail so however have done that it
will create an input model for me here
called robot input and I'll go to
Mathematica Oh file not found your input
so what's that let's go here hopefully
it is here file didn't open it open I
guess I have open reason somewhere but
there you go so now I have this model
here called writer which is very simple
and i created my robot input so what
I'll do here is I'll drag my robot input
and one of the small so there are many
small things added in system order to
help you in modeling one of those is
that for this robot input if you go to
the parameters before to change matrices
you have this small part here where you
had to kind of edit it now you have an
editor for a ray editor for doing your
your editors over eight so this is what
we generated from Mathematica and we
have a lot of like file editors color
Pickers and so on in order to avoid
using a code is that so now I'll just
connect this quickly run the last
example
there you go and run this and the
example I will get will be a small kind
of robot arm let's say that we'll get
some movement according to the input
data I gave it so let's look at that and
if you look at this this movement is now
given but how we design and does anybody
see what it's doing kind of hard so one
of the small things we added and was
that you can now trace a path so if I
for instance trace the tip of this there
we go we can see what has happened here
and so if i run it here typing it
instead we can see that we will be
writing wsf so that is a very small
thing but it makes it much easier to
understand what's going on right so
there's a bunch of those kind of things
done for use abilities make it easier to
understand what you're doing and to make
it easier to actually do it so and if
you want to see more tomorrow we have
open house where you can play around
with different examples robots footballs
songs so on we'll have a presentation on
the Wolfram language and how we will
work with the cloud that will be by
malta who's back there we'll have one on
how to bring your engineering course in
courses a lie which is the mother with
you one back there and that is on
thursday right and also on thursday you
will learn how to model ten helicopters
at once and that will show a little bit
more advanced concepts of system /
remove be done by Marcus well thank you
very much